IM: Wow, delish.
All right. So where should I position myself?
I want to stay out of the way. I don't want to be -- OK, here we go.
RO: Do you get nervous, Ashley?
Ashley: Doing what? RO: Cutting hair.
A: Never. I don't think there was ever a day when I cut hair I was nervous.
IM: You look so cute already. RO: You like it? All right.
IM: Do you have a problem looking cute? RO: Of course I want to look cute.
IM: Just checking, because some people want to look, you know, aggressively ugly.
RO: No, not me, no.
IM: You read about people who have a lot of money and they have kids
and the kids always end up somehow, really messed up, you know?
And there's got to be some way to do that, Rosie.
Just because you're fabulously rich and fabulously famous,
does that mean you shouldn't have kids,
because you know they're going to end up messed up?
RO: No, but it means your priority has to be their well-being first, I think.
But you have to make the decision for yourself.
My kids are seven, who the hell knows?
They're going to be like 14 and in rehab.
And they're going to be playing this clip. "I'm such a good mother."
My God, this is the shortest I've ever had!
IM: It looks good, yeah?
A: Has your hair ever been this short? RO: No! But it's all right -- go crazy.
IM: I feel like it needs to be closer down here.
A: It's just a stage. RO: We're just staging it.
IM: Are you freaking out? It's so cute.
RO: No, I love it. It's the new me. IM: It's so fabulous!
RO: Flock of Rosie. Wooo!
(Laughter)
IM: By the way, of all the most unboring things in the world, right?
I mean, like, making someone who's already cute look terrible like that --
(Laughter)
That is not boring. That is nothing if it's not boring.
Actually, I read this great quote the other day, which was,
"Style makes you feel great,
because it takes your mind off the fact that you're going to die."
Right?
(Laughter)
And then I realized that was on my website,
and it said, you know, the quote was attributed to me.
And I thought, "Oh, I said something in an interview. I forgot I said that."
But it's really true.
I want to show you this last clip because it's going to be my last goodbye.
I'll tell you that I cook a lot also.
I love to cook.
And I often look at things as though they're food.
Like, I say, "Would you serve a rotten chicken?
Then how could you serve a beat-up old dress or something?
How could you show a beat-up old dress?"
I always relate things to kitchen-ry.
(Laughter)
And so I think that's what it all boils down to.
Everything boils down to that.
So check this out.
This is what I've been doing,
because I think it's the most fun thing in the world.
It's, like, this website with a lot of different things on it.
It's a polymathematical website.
We actually shoot segments, like TV show segments.
And it's kind of my favorite thing in the world.
And it just began, like, in the beginning of February. So who knows?
Again, I don't say it's good, I just think it's not boring, right?
And here's the last bit.
(Music)
IM: I make buttermilk pancakes or buttermilk waffles all the time.
Sara Moulton: Do you?
IM: Yeah, but I can never find buttermilk, ever.
You can't find it at Citarella, you can't find it.
SM: You can't? IM: It's always low-fat.
SM: But that's all it is. IM: It is? OK.
SM: You don't know? Let me tell you something interesting.
IM: You know what? Stop laughing! It's not funny.
Just because I don't know there's no such thing as whole buttermilk.
Sorry. What?
SM: Here's the deal: in the old days, when they used to make butter --
You know how you make butter?
IM: Churn. SM: From cream.
IM: Yeah, exactly.
SM: So you take heavy, high-fat milk, which is cream,
and you churn it until it separates into these curds and water.
The liquid is actually -- if you've ever overbeaten your whipped cream,
it's actually buttermilk.
That's what it was in the early days.
And that's what people used for baking and all sorts of things.
Now the buttermilk that you get is actually low-fat or skim milk.
IM: Excuse me, I didn't know. Alright?
SM: The reason he thought that
is because buttermilk is so wonderfully thick and delicious.
IM: Yeah, it is. Exactly.
SM: So who would think that it was low-fat?
IM: Well, that's it. Thank you very much.
Happy TED. It's so wonderful here. I love it. I love it. I love it.
Thanks. Bye.